hey guys what's up I'm a lot of welcome
to my channel and today I'm going to be
unboxing and testing out the razors
siren approach I am really really
excited to have it's basically a
high-definition microphone from razor so
let's check it out
congratulations there's no turning back
there as your solder begins here whether
you're a youtuber stream or professional
musician your razor microphone has the
idea recording patterns for all your
broadcasting needs apparently a product
information guide okay and now a package
that says welcome to the cult of razor a
we have au XLR splitter cable I'm
probably not going to need that at home
an audio extension cable and a mini USB
to the USB cable
handy stuff okay so now we're a big ol
hunk of foam that I sure has a
microphone behind it oh this is a lot
bigger than I thought it would be damn I
really like the stand it means that you
don't need to have your own stand this
thing this is not sturdy this is
basically like a pillow that I'm sitting
this on right now I need a totally
stabilized itself that is awesome and
now the box is empty built into the mic
there are three 14 millimeter custom
chin condenser capsules in an array that
is capable for different recording
pattern configurations calling
resolution is 102 kHz / 24-bit which
razor hose is clarity levels multiple
times those found on CDs it also comes
with a built-in headphone amplifier for
monitoring with zero latency output when
plugged directly into the razer seiren
prop effectively meaning you can
accurately monitor all of your audio in
real time you can switch between the
four different polar recording patterns
that is compatible with by rotating main
control valve there's one for screaming
podcast voiceovers and it's
another four vocals another four
conference calls and events and finally
one for interviews and for gorgeo ads so
basically this one my connect is a party
on a stereo and oddly directional or a
bio direction on my can we have a
plugged in it is on actually I'll be
recording what I actually have set up to
record in some software um but the one
thing that I particularly like is this
here it shows your level but it also has
a symbol that indicates which of the
multiple recording patterns you are on
and by turning this knob here that
simple changes so I can see which one I
am set to so I guess you would have to
remember those four symbols and what
exactly they are but it is on the box
for easy consultation okay so testing it
out the headphones definitely have as
your delay I can hear everything really
really crisp and currently we're using
our standard cardioid mic which is good
one for stuff like podcasts and from
what I can hear I think this sounds
great so it would be as simple as
flipping that over and we are now on our
stereo mic this is ideal for
instrumentals and vocals like I can hear
a little bit of an echo in this one and
there's definitely some background noise
so my only real thoughts on the story
mic is that it does need a pop filter
but luckily you can get one it does also
come with a shock mount which would
effectively suspend it like if you're in
a radio studio and it all seems fairly
easy to put together but I don't think
I'm going to get any use out of this
stuff personally so then the next mode
that we have is omnidirectional that's
this one oh my god that's basically
gotten rid of all of the background
noise that's amazing so the
omnidirectional mic is supposed to be
good for events I'm just gonna play with
the mic volume think there sounds about
right so this one's supposed to be good
for events or conference calls yes does
an amazing job of cancelling out
background noise yep I'm a fan it's good
good work omnidirectional mic and the
last one we have is the bio directional
mic which I can't really effectively
test out without another person here and
as it is for 18 a.m. I don't think I'm
going to find anyone to help so I think
that I'm very happy with the quality of
this thing I'm happy with it being study
it hasn't moved despite being on a very
rough surface right now I guess the only
thing that I'm having trouble with is
because of the way that I have it I
can't actually see the levels so this
screen down here
shows your levels but I can't actually
see it when it's tilted towards me how
does it sound what it's not tilted
towards me you know what it still sounds
pretty damn good
it's yep it still sounds good I think
it's better when it's towards me but it
manages either way so we're just gonna
chuck it back on our omnidirectional for
my outro here because this one sounds
just amazing
I am Ilana this is the Razer siren Pro
and I hope you guys have enjoyed this
video I will see you all next time bye